tonight on Hotel Hell in Northern
California near Sacramento a 200 year
old hotel this is the actual bed that
President Grant's life in is about to
become history
look at the mold on that three buddies
decided to buy the business
are you guys really the [__] owners
but they're so busy drinking are you
drunk yes drink three for me
dancing they really like to give lap
dances lap dance and having fun but the
hotel and the guests
unaddlected if I don't do something soon
the town will lose its most important
historic building to a bunch of Frat
Boys
[Applause]
[Music]
forever
surrounded by the stunning Vineyards of
the Sierra Nevada Foothills is Murphy's
California a picturesque destination for
wine enthusiasts and tourists this
historic town has been home to Murphy's
hotel for over 150 years
the hotel has an illustrious history
presidents and legends have come to stay
in this national landmark
Partners Brian Kevin and Joel bought the
business nine months ago
I own a hotel with my two partners I run
the dining room I'm the dining room
manager Kevin he's our bar manager and
Joel he's our Chef wonderful thank you
but it's no one's job to look after the
hotel it's historic but I think it needs
to be maintenance
the historic rooms I wouldn't even stay
in them and I get a discount that's air
conditioning
behind the historic main building there
are 20 so-called modern bedrooms
[Music]
these are modern
I was like it too
[Music]
sadly the owners are too busy drinking
in the bar to notice the state of the
hotel oh man owning a bar at 32 years
old can be just a great party seven days
a week give it some time ready
he's out doing tonight what do you think
Kevin and I we love women and it is a
passion and we have a lot of them coming
through here don't act like you've never
done it you're not just all young we got
the cougar Clans coming through here we
are not one to discriminate we take
customer service to the next level
you know as a California American male
we were taught during college that uh
it's good been drinking is fun
why is everybody empty I am the fun
Captain she tried to Roofing me you see
that I am kind of The Party Guy I want
to make everyone have fun
[Applause]
kind of
enjoy drunken lap dance you've come to
the right place if you want a good
night's sleep you best go elsewhere I'm
exhausted and I keep hearing these loud
noises outside these people are drunk
and it's driving me crazy and I'm gonna
go complain
[Applause]
the saloon is always first and then the
hotel just seems like an afterthought
this registered national landmark has
been run ragged by the owners and is
hemorrhaging money
continue to party and not take things
seriously the hotel is just going to
close down if I don't do something fast
this place won't last another 150 days
let alone years I think Gordon is going
to say [__] this place that they're
screwed
[Music]
I'm on my way to Murphy's in Northern
California now this place is in among
some of the most stunning Vineyards
anywhere in the world
a beautiful Town look how busy this
place is as well listen with stunning
little tasting rooms now anyone lucky
enough to be running a small hotel here
should be sold out every night if
they're not they must be doing something
seriously wrong
[Music]
wow this really is a story Murphy's so
talent in place in the National relisher
of historic places nice wow hello how
are you I'm good how are you doing so
first name is
it always that busy out there
um we usually do get pretty busy on the
weekends incredible we have about 16
tasting rooms just within walking
distance of the hotel I love how
historic this place is but have you not
updated the furniture since 1850
let's see how my God it's like going to
your grandma's funeral oh my God they're
there is a difference between historic
and then tacky and old
looks like someone's died in those
chairs
so you've been here for a long time
about a year and a half and what's wrong
with the place
um well management the owners
be guys they're in their early 30s
there's Kevin Joel and Brian and they
really like to use the hotels their
playground
um partying drinking giving lap dances
to the bar patrons
there's lap dance lap dances while
they're bartending
the owners they continue partying and
giving lap dances in the bar and acting
how they've been the place is just going
to keep going downhill
we put you in the presidential Ulysses S
Grant room
this is the actual bed that President
Grant slept in except for the mattress
we did get rid of that what's the glass
box for um this is our display room
display room yes so guests and customers
can come up and take a look
when were these last um replaced
um [__] I can't really tell you that uh
it sounds like I'm in a museum so my
guest or an example you're a guest
tummy
come on through everybody
close the door close the door okay we're
gonna be on display today it's usual for
the tourists to come through sometimes
and if a guest checks in and they just
for some reason forget to close their
door they're gonna have people crowded
around looking at them
they literally come over and they hello
[Music]
that's embarrassing it's like a goldfish
Bowl in here ladies thank God I wasn't
in my Underpants
no they just come and have a look around
um yeah you know we normally get
complained playing and there's really no
one that handles that or takes care of
it but there's three owners yes a lot of
the time they're busy bartending or
drinking or lap dancing exactly
unfortunately
can this uh room be off the tour for a
while we'll see what we can do thank you
you're welcome
First Impressions I mean it may be
steeped in history but this smells like
the room is steeped in piss
we put you in the presidential Ulysses S
Grant room I've just arrived at Murphy's
hotel near Sacramento California it's
like I'm in a museum we're going to be
on display today hello thank God I was
in my Underpants
time for a bite to eat I hope the food
here is less stale than my bedroom
oh he looks a happy bunny oh hello how
are you part of your one party one not
party for one uh good to see you I'm
Brian is that the same
congratulations Employee of the Month
um did you get a bonus do you get a nice
day
I'm one of the only employees that never
made the cut yet I see you just put
yourself in and what are the owners
gonna say about that I'm one of them
I'm Brian stop it yes come on hey the
other owners out there shot on there
you're the owner and you made yourself
Employee of the Month yeah
are you the man with the G string the G
string reception tell me did you do lap
dancing oh no that would probably be
Kevin RC I don't know my Booty's a
little too big to do the Last Dance okay
I was gonna say I can't wait to see that
one I would love to meet the other two
the chef and the lap dancer are they
around I think you want to bring them
out yeah all right Kevin and Joel and I
we're all equal shareholders in this
business but it was my plan to buy the
hotel hello Kevin Kevin come on good to
see you back and this is hi Gordon Joel
Joel so you're the lap dancer
maybe once in a while but okay fine I'm
a wild one when I started drinking I get
a little strippered action going on or
be a little Rowdy and can be the most
fun at any young adult could ever dream
of
so obviously the chef yes restaurant
manager
on the lap dancer bar manager bar
manager so who's in charge
all three of us
no such thing
so who runs the hotel who's in charge of
the the hotel hotel manager job doesn't
really entail much
free owners normally there's one that
takes the reins and two other silent
none of you sound and look like an owner
well Gordon thinks we don't look like
owners but what what's the owner look
like we bought the hotel nine months ago
right and you guys go back a long way
just kind of met each other 15 years ago
and I'm confused whether it's the Three
Musketeers or three stooges
anyway I'm gonna have a quick bite to
eat it's been a long journey I'm excited
to taste the food thank you nice to meet
you thank you Gordon's gonna love our
food Joel works really hard at
everything he puts out everything that
comes out the window is a great product
I can't believe this hotel is owned by
three guys with a pink dining room
Pink's a new black well it's like a
girl's bedroom
[Music]
any specials on today we had a fresh
Alaskan halibut with uh
now that I'm talking to you I've
completely forgot no we had we had the
Halibut with a
well this is the first time I forget
specials don't worry why don't you check
with the chef all right I will you have
a Russian measure right yes and I was a
server too Russian manager employ the
mum an owner yes all the above employee
of the month I'm gonna take that plaque
back I can't even remember the specials
Hey Joe I forgot the special just now
Ryan just kind of Forgotten specials I
have seen him do that before the
specials available tonight the
macadamian encrusted halibut right let's
try this guy entrees lamb shank and then
what's the color my door what does door
mean it's a doorway it's just a calamari
steak oh I'll go for that as well okay
thank you I'll keep all the menu thank
you very much you're welcome once Gordon
has a bite of Jewel's food order in he's
gonna put a smile on his face guaranteed
thank you
Cargo in a red wine garlic sauce big one
garlic
wow
absolutely rancid criminal taste
I mean
nothing's hot
uh yeah strange taste you know that's
the first actually the first time in the
history that I've eaten the escargal oh
really and I'm gonna say that I I don't
like it in any way no the escargo tasted
like a dirty funky it's disgusting
flip-flop if you sauteed a flip-flop I
think that would be a good good way of
describing it that was [__]
disgusting
I do I want to run home and get some
mouthwash for sure but I don't know do
whatever you need to all right yeah
because I stink
the last water for you okay please
do you have any um little samples of
like wine flights anything Regional
we've talked about that but we have not
implemented it
so you've been talking about it for nine
months but you haven't actually done it
yet no one's even
bothered this sort of wine flight so
trying to get it together so so we've
had this place almost a year and you
haven't implemented something that this
town thrives on correct right
we taste there's a skunk I mean there's
cargo not really have you eaten I mean
you eat here right not very often when
was the last time you guys sat down and
had dinner in the restaurant never sat
down with all three of us together it's
strange stranger I'm getting slightly
nervous that nothing actually gets done
here
anyway I'm living in hope I have some
more bread for sure
I had a lamb chain coming right out bro
oh my God
[Music]
holy crap what is that this is our lamb
shank that's a weird looking lamb shank
visually it looks like the biggest plate
of puke I've never personally had lamb
shank ever been here I do not like lamb
are you the Russian manager you don't
like lamb don't eat the scars yeah I'm
the restaurant manager but I'm not I'm
not the chef wow I think I would just
call that a dog's dinner what a mess
I do apologize again
I'm totally embarrassed that our food is
as quality I've always thought it was
better hey Joel yes the lamb shank he
mentioned that the vegetable gravy goo
was a little little too much oh okay I'm
gonna run this out okay
fine dining Frozen and edible nasty
Extra Man I mean I'm amazed what's this
one this is the calamari Dore steak
that's not garlic in there again is it
there is garlic in there again geez it's
just how that dish is prepared
everything's just laced with garlic
please
be my guest I I
what is it trying to be the sponge
damn embarrassed I'm chewing on it going
I just want to spit this [__] out right
now like this is terrible so that's the
first bite I've ever taken of that you
know this stuff's on the menu right
you're aware of it this is your hotel
yes yes it's not being punked here that
you guys are their owners we are the
owners we always have them send their
sons in to take the hit no no you
definitely are the owner this is us okay
how do these three stooges qualify to
run an Historic Hotel like this
but they can't even get the food and
wine right how they're going to improve
the hotel I feel like I'm being looked
after by college kids
probably be good yeah come on out
sorry I'm very impressed uh no I mean
far from impressed have you ever
actually stood back and looked at that
lamb shank as a dish and it's most
horrendous the most drobby disgusting
looking [__] lamb shank
have you given up nope no no way we just
started we're not giving up here you
just started yeah
it just walked in from outside checked
in went up to the rooms and you've never
done that ever have you ever done that
no sir have you ever done that I have
not oh my god what have you improved on
says you bought it truthfully and make
people laugh and smile every day
seriously what have you changed weekends
we serve breakfast all day what have you
changed menu wise manual
um [__] hell
I got one two three
idiots that haven't changed anything
[Music]
you don't stay here you don't eat
together you don't criticize the food
[__] reception
room
ship food and three clueless owners
owners my [__] ass
I'm staying at Murphy's hotel in
Northern California and after being put
on display for gorking tourists
and eating an atrocious lunch I think I
would just call that a dog's dinner what
a mess
I need to see the three nitwit owners in
action
word has got out that I'm in Murphy's
and the hotel and restaurant are full of
people I feel sorry for all of them
Joel is running the kitchen chickens
burn Kevin is getting busy in the bar
and Brian is overseeing the dining room
cheese
I mean
so guess trying to check in are left to
fend for themselves
[Music]
is um everything okay uh yeah we're
waiting we went up to the front desk and
there's nobody there so I'm trying to
check in for the uh it's one of the
owners never mind I guess I just arrived
to check in you get Brian urgently or
Kevin what about it about I guess
checking in oh yes check-in I can do
that yeah would you please I'm sorry
thank you excuse me you should have to
come looking for us in the bar
so that's what happens when guests come
in late they go to the bar looking for
yes that is uh how are we doing have you
ever done that checked in and then found
the reception close and went into the
bath looking for a cake no no I've
actually only stayed at hotels probably
only a matter of 20 times in my entire
life on your hotel owner yeah so how
come you guys don't have anybody up here
we got the bartenders or servers like me
sometimes taking care of it
once guests get to the rooms they're in
for another unpleasant surprise
[Music]
let's wait for the drunkards to go home
before we open that up
yeah
have a good night it's very noisy in
there from the bar in the street
the owner's ignorance is evident in
everything I've seen so far I'm curious
to see what it's like in the past I
haven't seen like the walk-in fridge
[Music]
cooked [__] disgusting I wish I'd
seen this before I had my lunch fine
dining it's not because [__] the mold
going on there
bloody hell there's mole at the sides
too
oh Jesus Christ look at the [__] mold
on that this is absolutely disgusting
wow so the walk-in how often is that
fridge cleaned out
twice a week yes
everything out yes yeah yes come with me
all of you all right especially the
owners sounds good sounds good really
[__] you now
oh wow
look at moldy tortillas there should not
be [__] any moldy [__] food
[__] horrible and when was this maze
last Saturday oh I needed to go I smell
that you need to toss it I know that
I'm this terrible you should be [__]
ashamed okay okay no it's not okay what
is that uh black mold what's it supposed
to be Thai Chili marinade Thai Chili
marinade has been used in a while the
sauces was from a chef that had been
there like in 2006 or seven or something
this is exactly the same way as you run
this [__] hotel
you don't give a [__]
I give you [__] I give a [__] and this
is your dream of running a hotel they're
about Manning up and look like [__]
owners we are this is [__]
unacceptable and it's not gonna happen
anymore have you checked out because you
should do Your Own Thing say to these
two [__] it it's not checked out you can
talk I have not checked out and I
obviously I need to pay more attention
and do better at my job how many of you
can run a [__] business do you ever
see three CEOs three hockey general
managers no three [__] executive
chefs ah it's like
since my arrival at Murphy's hotel in
Northern California used to be [__]
ashamed I've been appalled by the three
clueless owners dumbest
are you guys really the [__] owners
true story
[__] off
[Music]
unbelievable I mean three young idiots
that are playing at running a hotel and
not one of them were a [__] clue
I'm mad at Joe I'm a [__] owner I
don't [__] want to clean I've been
here 12 hours it's unacceptable
I do want to improve Gordon Ramsay wrong
about me being a [__] idiot [__]
dumb and dumber [__] scoundrel wanker
[__] whatever British [__]
terminology that [__] wanker has to
say across from the [__] different
bottom guy but I do respect him time to
get a drink
I'm gonna go play poker in Reno later
tonight because I'm not going to sleep
listen to the [__] music
how on Earth is anyone gonna ever get to
sleep in this hotel Jesus Christ
that's crazy you know what
Frog's asses for everyone in this
building right here right now
[Applause]
what is this this doesn't make sense
[Music]
[Applause]
there's got to be a quieter room
somewhere
[Music]
[Applause]
One Nation [__]
[Music]
please
oh [__] here we go
hey I I have a walk-in to clean I've
been here I want to go get that cleaning
because it's number one right now
this is a joke
is this a joke third partying and I'm
upset and uh we're just I don't know
they're partying
they wanted to see it and uh I was upset
earlier and I'm upset and Joel I'm not
upset at everything that's going on and
I want this is I'm just upset thank you
for two minutes about your guess I want
to go I'm going to go clean the walking
I'm going to clean the walking just walk
off like that you know what I'm gonna go
clean the walking because you know why
why are you acting like a [__] jerk
because I'm I'm upset that was [__]
unacceptable there's unacceptable the
[__] walking with the [__] black
mold so why don't you do something about
it hey I was I if I was
foreign
is coming undone and is drinking on the
job I'm done trying to get through to
him today I'm I'm upset I was [__]
unacceptable in there okay
go home all right
I'm gonna do it in a t-shirt Jesus
Christ I've been told the hotel offers
modern rooms further from the bar so
I've asked to be put in one so I can get
away from all this madness
[Music]
and they call these modern rooms it
looks like my grandma's house from the
1950s look at this wallpaper hideous and
what sort of hotel is this when you
can't go
[Applause]
this was supposed to be quieter down
here
[Music]
what an awful nice sleep
foreign
[Music]
this place is such a mess from the awful
Decor to the Dreadful food to the
drunken partying all night long I need
to get the whole team together and find
out how it's gotten into this state
good morning it's uh go downstairs have
a meeting feel good yeah
[Music]
good
[Applause]
man that was a bad night's sleep the
noise above here was insane I came back
downstairs last night and Brian's
ripping his shirt up shouting screaming
about hey shots all on me is that normal
is that really how these managers
operate when they're off duty they come
behind the bar turn up the Jukebox when
I've already turned it down pour
themselves drinks it's their personal
frat house
how does that make you feel your
employees are concerned that you're
drunk in the bath
when do I treat you all [__] badly
what yeah when it comes to scheduling
how many days that you guys have asked
off for that you didn't get off it's not
more Oscar
if you're gonna run a hotel it's not
about having a [__] party it's about
levels of discipline well just so you
know it's not happening anymore but I'm
not gonna be as happy sometimes for you
guys
as far as good as your team they
represent you and based on what I've
seen I don't think you represent them
properly okay if you go first and tell
these owners what they need to hear we
lose a lot of reservations when we don't
have somebody to answer the phone you
know when we leave the front desk we put
the phone in the bar after 8 PM we are
the front desk we are the bartenders I
saw that last night yeah they don't
answer the phone because they don't hear
it
we need online booking you know what
that takes away online bookings as front
desk girls you know we've talked about
getting rid of the front desk and
putting a computer there we don't have a
person there self check-in so how do you
feel about that so they can play and you
threatened to fire them yeah no that's
not what it is yes it is yes it is you
just totally attacked me I'm afraid to
express my feelings I'm afraid I'm gonna
get fired ready nobody's threatened here
with their job nobody has you never
threatened me by being fired I have
before were you drunk yes you were drunk
that's the message I'm trying to get
through to your fake skulls
being staff whilst inebriated it's crazy
people who deserve to be fired are these
three standing here there's no there's
no structure
somebody needs to step up and run the
business and everybody else follows suit
you need one general manager that's the
issue you need to be a leader from the
top that's one person there can be 25
owners but there needs to be one general
manager if something doesn't change you
guys are going to lose this place
okay which one of you is capable of
stepping up and running this business
I'm at Murphy's hotel in Northern
California you're the owner and you made
yourself Employee of the Month yeah the
place is a mess because these three
owners behave like Frat Boys cheers boys
and girls
and none of them is a leader you've
checked out so the staff don't know
which way to turn I'm afraid to express
my feelings I'm afraid I'm gonna get
fired things have got to change
there needs to be one general manager
somebody needs to take charge
[Music]
I'm gonna take charge I'm going to run
to business I'm our leader out of us
three it's going to be me guaranteed if
you're gonna run the hotel you got it
you run the hotel yeah 100 so Kevin and
Joel are you willing to give him the
support and the autonomy to actually run
this place
yes
Brian it's your responsibility now to
General manage an absolutely toe the
line but there are three rules rule
number one to stop drinking on the floor
gotcha rule number two they have to stop
working the floor yeah and rule number
three you have to [__] grow some fast
Brian does know the most out of the
three of them so I really do think if he
could stop his party in ways he could
really do it trust me if you don't grow
up now you never will I got it it's a
hotel not a frat house I'm not going to
be drinking and uh I'm gonna be owner
thank God for that
thank you thank you I'm going to change
I'm going to be more of an owner and not
a friend slash co-worker and they're
going to see a different Brian
the future of this historic national
landmark is now in Brian's hands and I
need to know that he cares enough to be
responsible you are young ambitious
slightly naive you're going at it in
totally the wrong way you're on the
verge of losing this business hopefully
not and how would you feel if you lost
the business it would be horrible it'd
be horrible because that's already the
years of uh 60 hour weeks it's horrible
I'm here to help
but I wouldn't understand the mess
you're in it's not good all right
do you understand I do I think down
inside there's no two ways better you're
a fun guy I've got a lot to offer yeah
but just stop being irresponsible ever I
just man up yeah for sure you can do it
okay
I want to make this work
um
from today on it's going to be a change
business is different all right
okay I could see that small back in your
face thank you I'll see you later from
this day forward I'm a change man and
the business is going to reflect all
those changes
with Brian ready to take charge as
general manager my design team has
worked all night to modernize Murphy's
hotel and now it's time to reveal the
new look hotel to Brian and his team
Brian how is that Gordon good how are
you doing we're very smart are you good
you doing I'm good my ladies how are we
yeah
right welcome everyone the new and
improved Murphy's Historic Hotel are you
ready ready
welcome
new Lobby all right I know it is awesome
exactly how it should be
nice yeah when I first walked in I was
disappointed it was just like I began to
climax now you have a nice warm modern
feel the minute you walk in oh your
guests will arrive and fail welcomed
yeah take a seat as the beautiful yes
amazing beautiful amazing what do you
think beautiful absolutely beautiful
welcoming tell us the contrast the wall
perfect what Gordon has done with the
lobby is beautiful now that blue it's so
warm it's so welcoming it's awesome this
is a Historic Hotel your ex-president
stayed here yes that doesn't happen
they're often in hotels
this morning you're now live with online
bookings
[Applause]
I don't go anywhere near the bar you
know what time they're coming and you
are now in the 21st century are you
ready to see the presidential suite yeah
yeah all right come and see my room
let's go
I think you'll love it let's go jump in
oh my God that is awesome
this one's been freshened up this one's
been spruced up you need that Vibrance
the minute you walk into a room you want
to feel wow I'm stepping into history
but I also want some comfort this is fit
for a president our president now could
stay here Obama would be be okay to stay
here now it still feels historic but
it's a bedroom not a museum yeah exactly
so you know make sure that when your
guests are checked in their bedrooms are
off the tour did you put a new robes is
there something on here this will be
lined and cushions
for me the big problem wasn't the Linens
it was the noise we've come up with a
solution to narrow that down last time
it's midnight well stick to those times
of your bar closing because the damage
you can do to your reputation is
devastating yep we're going to follow
through and make sure that our customers
in the hotel are as happy as our
customers in the bar and our customers
in the restaurant
all right so you ready to see the rooms
outside that you told me were modern
right
let me show you what modern is you ready
yeah
no way
you can see why I got upset the owner's
done nothing in nine months we've done
all this in [__] 24 hours
I'm blown away I can't believe the the
creativity that's been put into this
place in the last few days Joe what do
you think
um Last Words inspired you know very
inspiring you know they said you should
never ever ever be afraid of change
you've got to keep on going oh yeah yeah
every time Brian what do you think
what's going through your mind I've
never heard you so quiet breathtaking no
I don't even know what to say because
it's beautiful it's just something
beautiful this is perfect with this kick
in the ass we're gonna go forward Full
Throttle we're gonna make changes that
no one's ever seen before you ready to
see the dining room yes
the dining room
look at the colors come in oh my God
beautiful where's the pink oh my God
yeah John are those horrendous pink
walls a stunning beautiful color on the
walls that just pop and there's one more
thing
this bed you're gonna love it's a
surprise that's going to completely
change your business you ready for this
yes
I've just revealed the stunning new
improvements to the historic Murphy's
Hotel
[Music]
that will ensure this hotel thrives in
the future you are in the heart of some
of the most sought after wineries
anywhere in the world and it's a massive
Market that you have been missing out on
and here's why every famous Winery has a
lovely Tasting Room on this Main Street
at five o'clock they close here you're
now going to pick up that business this
is a menu designed to pair with great
local wines
oh my gosh start off with that lovely
cheese plate the chicken liver crostini
paired with a stunning chilled Rose and
then this wonderful local local ricotta
dip you now have a perfect menu when
those tasting rooms close at five
o'clock you pick it up and you continue
it and where they're gonna stay the
night yeah yeah that's right after
dinner I want you to dig in and Sample
the Wayne TC menu is awesome the overall
experience to any guest that walks
through our door now I believe is going
to be better than ever I like the
pairing of the bruschetta and the wine
that I go there there's a very nice
fresh dish there's no going back no
you're only going up now yeah
oh that's nice oh this is so phenomenal
this is gonna put us on the map
off the charts reservations off the hook
thank you Chef thank you as well as a
wine pairing menu I've changed the
entire menu in the dining room let me
show you one of my favorite dishes I'm
very excited about the new menus I know
where I'm eating every night oh my God
fresh baked lemon meringue pie oh my
goodness look at that thing the real
inspiration behind this was Brian's hair
[Applause]
is going to touch a business a clientele
that we've never had at the Murphy's
hotel and I know personally I can't wait
to eat there more often
with warm and fresh rooms and the new
wine tasting menu my only concern is
whether Brian can stay focused on the
guest experience I listen every night
from now on in this hotel is a big night
let me tell you and it's not just about
the past but the restaurant and the
rooms push those tasting menus in that
bar GM are you ready we're ready um if
there's one thing you do not need as a
general manager as an apron get that off
all right
good luck guys
[Applause]
hello how are you doing good how are you
with extended front desk operating hours
guests can easily check in and feel
welcome in the new Lobby
[Music]
it's nice I'll bet it would be a
comfortable sleep I know it's going to
be fun and they're enjoying the
renovated and peaceful rooms
this is the Newsome Harlow and the wine
tasting menu is a hit absolutely looks
lovely guys they're loving the food keep
it going well done and good luck
my first arrived you saw three young
guys sort of playing at running a bar
and completely forgetting that they were
actually in charge of a hotel but Brian
stepped up and has taken that general
manager role which is great news I'm
hoping now that they get that party mode
out of their mind and focus on the
potential of what this business can
bring them
great job
um you performed like owners tonight you
sound like owners and this place you
know is rocking the atmosphere in the
bar is controlled the dining room's
having fun the patio is full the wine
tasting menu is flying out keeping the
good work okay Gordon he really has
opened my eyes and showed me that we
need to take more of a leadership role
as an owner I'll take you out of the
employee of the month I know choose one
together yes on a monthly basis have
your input yeah throw it into the pot I
believe Gordon has saved his place by
putting wind in our sails again we truly
did need a kick in the ass because we
were playing around a little too much
actions speak louder your next day
you'll hear great things I guarantee
Gordon is amazing he's a magician and I
think that he came through and he
transformed the hotel into this
wonderful Masterpiece and I'm so
thankful that he came through and helped
us what a gorgeous place
I never did get to see Kevin Love dance
since my visit to the historic Murphy's
Hotel the owners have finally become
owners Joel is keeping the kitchen and
the walk-in extra clean and he has new
pride in his work I got a well done
going right there you can go peek at the
upstairs bathrooms one's down the hall
showers both restrooms upstairs yeah you
stay there I'm good we're here Brian is
stepping up as general manager focusing
his efforts on the hotel Brian is
definitely capable of being the general
manager Gordon has completely changed
everything
Historic Hotel back to life
tonight on Hotel Hell I'm in Longview
Washington trying to save one of the
Pacific Northwest precious gems which
has been shamefully neglected oh my gosh
the wealthy Hotel owner has a drinking
problem that is spiraling out of control
owner jailed developed is arrested for
DUI
50 devoted staff are desperate to save
their jobs we care about this place and
we care about you but a lot of us feel
like you don't give a damn about us
you're calling your staff Liars I call
them [__] Liars can I get this hotel
back on the wagon before it's too late
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Washington voted one of America's
prettiest towns is home to a Pacific
Northwest Jewel the Monticello Hotel
built in 1923 this historic building is
currently celebrating its 90th
anniversary but unlike cheese and good
wine some things do not get better with
age
oh my gosh
I'm Philip loving plus and I'm the owner
of the Monticello Hotel I wanted to own
the hotel since I was eight years old my
mother worked here when I was very young
and I remember all the cocktail
waitresses and how beautiful they were
and wanted to be a part of it some might
say the story of how Philip lovingfoss
obtained the hotel is almost too good to
be true others might call it a fairy
tale Philip was a bartender here he fell
in love with the owner Annabelle Jewel I
was in my early 30s when Annabelle and I
first started going together and she was
in her mid-60s
they were married and when Annabelle
passed away all of her assets
were given to Philip he inherited the
Monticello Hotel
it's all pretty
with his inheritance Philip has been
living the good life with his girlfriend
and general manager Ginger who's also 30
years senior TJ but despite the owner's
fabulous wealth the staff are underpaid
I still make minimum wage and I've been
here 12 years
hey we're getting into that
flaunts his wealth in front of us don't
flaunt it in our face when we're all
wondering do we put gas in the car or do
we buy groceries
this is [__] unreal
he's probably got 150 000 worth of
diamonds on his right arm 10 karat
diamond ring on his left finger he
walked through the kitchen one day and
and somebody broke his glass and he said
hold on lose a stone I mean really how
[__] arrogant I want to say [__] you
while Philip and ginger have been
enjoying their wealth the hotel has been
terribly neglected
cigarette Burns
seriously that is so gross
all the way down the hall around the
corner inside the beautiful historic
Monticello Hotel there were only four
Suites and then there are countless
rooms stuffed with Phillip and Ginger's
crap instead of guests
with only four guest bedrooms available
in the main Hotel most guests are
unwittingly given rooms in the so-called
North Wing which is a characterless
1960s shoebox Motel Next Door I was
hoping to stay in the hotel
extender now and having been ignored for
years the hotel is not generating any
new business with a rapidly dwindling
client base
glamorous hotel has major problems
but Philip's problem may be the biggest
it is no big secret that Philip drinks
Philip will come in here drunk good job
good job in front of all the staff and
it's just an embarrassing mess
[Music]
the day before I arrived in Longview
things reach crisis point I was pulled
over
and they charged me with a DUI I was a
place under arrest they booked me in the
Cowlitz County jail and yesterday
morning I was released it's an
unfortunate situation
thank you you guys have a good night
this hotel its staff and the community
deserve better
Phil talked about closing it Gordon
isn't able to save this place for us
um 50 people will be out of jobs and
Phil will be on his yacht in Seattle
drunk
this place is a gem that needs to be
preserved it's the heart of Longview
this town needs the Monticello
[Music]
gorgeous that place is massive look at
all those rooms for guests finally
somewhere nice to stay I feel sorry for
the crappy Motel Next Door I'm amazed
that place is still open right next to a
big hotel like that my God
yeah
one of those beautiful cars it must be a
car show on
oh no somebody having a laugh Hotel Hell
that is nine who the [__] can't spell
part-time housekeeper I can't do
anything worse to advertise on the
outside of your hotel
[Music]
good morning good morning and first name
is Vanessa Vanessa I see you're having a
classic car show today no those all
belong to our owner Phillip no stop they
do
they belong to the owner what's with the
plate that's like Hotel Hell on one of
the plates yes
yes so for me I'm not sure if you did it
for your
employer of the month 2010. you know
it's
2013. I do yes are the staff that bad
that hasn't been a more recent employee
of the month last I heard actually he
was in jail holy crap we have so many
great employees it's ridiculous that
we're not recognized more than we are
here's your card and here is your room
code you're in room 220. uh will you
show me the way or oh sure if you'd like
shall we please if you'll follow me I've
got that and we're going outside yes
okay just across here so you have to go
out to get back up again yes
and 220 right here
um but this is not the Hotel this is our
Northland Motel
why in the [__] would I want to stay in
there
I'd rather stay in there next door okay
than in this dump I'm sorry people want
to stay in the hotel they don't want to
stay in the Cracker Box driving up here
didn't expect to be put in a motel no I
understand and I'm I am sorry
all right it's just right over here
thank you you're welcome let's see how
sofas hidden
hit yourself like that
oh my God it gets worse in here this bed
is this auntie uh no the rooms are
furnished completely with stuff from
Phillip and Ginger's home oh dear his
mattress from the house yes
being a mattress from your house into
your hotel I wouldn't they charge 250 a
night for that mattress I don't even
know what to say about it when they get
new stuff they bring old stuff here
there's some storage rooms that are full
of all furniture where the storage
places
jeez it's like a sweet just full of crap
it's like a dumping crab
there's more too wow you are kidding me
not oh my God look at this
I wish I was kidding it's like a hoarder
it's just junk everywhere I don't
understand the hotel owner that would
dump half a ship hotel rooms and not
rent them out Garden was pretty appalled
that the state of the storage rooms how
much crap there was in there it's just a
big [__] waste I appreciate it thank
you
wow this place is so disappointing the
biggest highlight so far is the drive up
the minute you step inside it's just
bizarre I can't wait to meet the owner
and find out what the hell is going on
in his head
I've just arrived at the Monticello
Hotel in Longview Washington and I'm
shocked to discover that there are only
four rooms for guests in this Grand
Place While others are being used for
storage oh my God it's like a hoarder
it's just junk everywhere I've got to
meet the owner and the general manager
and figure out what else is wrong with
this place
let's see
very nice to see you and welcome to the
Monticello thank you what a gorgeous
place from the outside thank you how are
you good so you're Ginger yes this is my
significant other hello
[Music]
there you go is that true
it's true wow look at that bling look it
looks like a Super Bowl ring
do you have it for me
um I thought it was a car Fair here so
someone told me they're yours never mind
amazing
let's give it to the lounge
did you always want to own a hotel ever
since I was a little kid I wanted to go
in this house serious and what's the
building worth now probably three and
five million it's extraordinary I
inherited it oh real estate yes and if
you don't mind me asking what was that
the tune of tonight wow is the hotel
making money or losing money I've been
carrying it how much you're losing 30 to
35 000 a month oh lose it that's 400
Grand a year
that's insane there's lots of sleepless
nights for me how are we losing so much
money being taken advantage of I know
that who's taking advantage the kitchen
staff for sure
they wait and leave the clock
it's a thing you can get paid for hours
that you're not working they can't do
that to you
I think Gordon's going to have
difficulties with my employees I don't
see them as team players at all if this
place was taken away what would it mean
to you yeah it would be equivalent to a
death oh geez I started here in 1973.
this has been a huge part of my life Wow
well let's give an Insight let me tell
you
um Ginger nice to see you very nice
likewise thank you thank you
thank you so much it's terrible to hear
that Philip and ginger I've been taking
advantage of by their staff when they
clearly care so much I really hope I can
help them sort their employers out oh
hello good evening how are you I'm fine
I'm Debbie Debbie Gordon nice to see I
have a table for you right over here now
how long have we been here I have been
here 12 years wow seriously 12 years yes
um right what would you recommend I
recommend
our crab and artichoke dip okay let's
get for one of those all right
Phillips triple Tower yes what's that
it's a three-tier Tower of three
different appetizers and is his name big
enough on the menu there obviously
suffering from small man syndrome let's
go for that and then the bassinet
ravioli let's try that all right thanks
nice to see you
so the appetizers first place okay well
I'm feeling really nervous about cooking
for Gordon these are all [__] froze
together most of the food is
pre-packaged or canned or frozen because
Ginger and Philip are running this place
like real misers they uh Pinch A Penny
on every corner
this is our crab and artichoke dip it's
served with deep fried pita bread and um
is it fresh crab or canned frozen chili
and crab frozen chili and crab correct
[__] snot dip
I mean it's like a dish ready for one of
Phillip's girlfriends no teeth oh God
it's got a sour taste to it I don't know
what it is I know Jesus
he felt it tasted sour it always got
that taste to me I don't like it
you are kidding me
off the tower this is the tower this is
the tower oh my gosh holy Mackle so
it's like something you should have in
your [__] Garden or in your
restaurant are those shrimp are they
fresh are they frozen they're frozen
they're frozen damn
[Music]
I'm here
teriyaki beef tips
Jesus
that sauce is hideous
and that middle one's another portion of
snot dip I'll skip that well
unfortunately for the chef he doesn't
get to dictate his own menu
Chef doesn't like his own menu he does
not
shall we wake up careful
so Philips dictating the menu I suppose
if his staff can't be trusted to clock
in and out they can't be trusted to
choose the food
feedback on that um the meat is too
tough
the sauce tastes weird he can tell it's
not homemade
we're just Ramses
and it is the meat is too tough yeah
it's getting the full picture and that's
just what I wanted
right I feel very good about it I am
very disappointed with Dan's food it's
horrible I just hope that Gordon sees
the problems with the staff
ravioli
I'm dreading bringing this dish out to
him right now that Butternut rapidly
thank you thank you who made the uh
raviolis I don't know the name of the
manufacturer manufacturer correct so the
rubbery's aren't even made either they
are not made here oh Jesus they're
packaged
that's Dreadful like a mouthful of sugar
every time
oh dear thank you wow
frozen crab frozen shrimp pre-packaged
ravioli it's more like eating a badly
Renault folks home than a decent
restaurant
obviously from a package we all do that
one was coming
I think there's a better way than the
art kitchen can function than it's
functioning right now I see just blatant
neglect
um tell me about Phillips management
style well when he's sober I get along
with him just fine
when he's drinking I avoid him at all
costs does he drink a lot on sites he
does on a scale of one to turn how bad
is he drinking now at 10.
this week he was arrested
for what DUI
you are [__] kidding me I'm not
kidding oh my God I want to see the
hotel owner jailed jailed he's kept
overnight in jail
why would he not tell me that well it
just happened hours ago Phillips in
denial he doesn't take responsibility
for his drinking problems and I felt
Gordon needed to know
[Music]
how else
um why don't you ask the chef to come
out of the dining room I'd like to meet
him and bring Philip and ginger as well
thank you
[Music]
he would like to see you all in the
dining room
I'm lots of words Chef that was Dreadful
I don't think anything was fresh it
takes extra time to do things homemade
yeah naturally we're on a timer string
what ask how many hours they get in a
week or whatever and they got to scrape
for out my my prep cook gets 20 hours a
week
that's not enough time to make fresh
food is that why all the food's Frozen I
mean I get cut carrots or cut celery in
the bag I get the boiled eggs in a bag
done peeled you buy in boiled eggs yes
I played the Safeguard and
purchase supposedly prepared you played
the safe cart we can't even boil a
[__] egg in here Philip if you care
about quality you need to pay people to
prep fresh food not buy it in there are
times uh you know January February where
I'd have 12 16 hours a week a week yeah
how do you survive
three hours a day
not very well but do you have a family
yes I do damn seven kids
this is insane
you can't run this hotel like a miser
if I sold [__] three of those cars
and put it into the kitchen budget to
function for the next 12 months the
chefs can do their job
and speaking of cars why don't you tell
me about this
foreign
[Music]
ER jailed jailed and I've just
discovered that the hotel owner has a
drinking problem so bad that just one
day before I arrived he was arrested for
drunk driving
I have a word with the owner please yes
what's going on
truthfully
have you had a drink today no
yes you have
your staff
tell me that you have a drinking problem
no
and yet you've just been busted for DUI
Ginger
does your boyfriend have a drinking
problem
he does like his libations
I'm pissed off that you couldn't even
say hey Gordon can have a word no
problem having a conversation all over
the newspaper
I'm aware of that who owns this place me
so when are you going to step up I'm
your Gordon I'm engaged if you can't be
honest with yourself
[Music]
the facts are starting to become clear
the problem here isn't the staff it's
the owner you have
um room service we do not
no room service in a hotel this size
that's not the only unpleasant surprise
guest check-in and just like me they
think they're going to get a room in a
historic gem but instead they're placed
in the motel
sample
and a fettuccine alfredo is ready and
during dinner service most of the guests
are over the age of 17 there clearly
hasn't been any Buzz about this place in
decades yes sir that's not a prime rib
should be a little moisture in there
shouldn't it I can go and check and see
if there's another income back there Dan
do we have another
juicy
explain when you do this no no why all
of a suddenly he's involved
because I'm here I'm sorry
strawberry daiquiri
I can't believe Philip is put on a show
for me well if you want to know the
truth about a drinker ask the bartender
Grant what is going on tonight it's like
a comedy of errors here you're welcome
no no what does Philip normally do at
the hotel he does drink quite a bit
wow and on average a day how many drinks
would you make a day during the day
sometimes four or five and then it jumps
into the evening
it could come up to uh seven eight
I had him cut off of a new one oh wow
wow now one of the things are on the
slide with Philip drinking that much
I've got to get him to tell me the truth
this monstrous hotel has been running
rudderless there's no one at the helm
and you're pretending all of a sudden
I'm busy I'm actually without lifting
because I'm here I I just no stop
because you're here we don't normally do
this stuff this is what I normally do
you're calling your star of liars I
would say so if they say that I'm not
out here helping them every time I walk
in this building I would call them
[__] Liars
do you think I can just wave a [__]
[__] My Places run into the ground
[Music]
with dinner service over what she says
I'm gonna get Philip and his staff
together so I can finally get to the
truth
is that normal what I witnessed tonight
is Philip always here does Philip always
expedite the [__] hot plate no no
we need somebody to expedite we're
understaffed and if we get busy then we
can't give good service and those people
will not come back a person can't
shortcut like that because of this place
the business being strangled yeah it's
been strangled by the owner
why are we pretending I'm doing a good
job of pretending then this is what I do
every time that you come in here this is
what you do I do not run food down to
your bar for the last couple nights
let's talk about the elephant in the
room shall we
oh
when Phillip's drinking he behaves one
or two different ways either he's jovial
and likes to giggle and have a good time
or if finances are in arrears that we
hear about how much everything costs you
and you were going to close the doors
it's stressful it's not easy to come to
work with someone threatening us all the
time that the doors are going to be
closed please don't look at me like that
Phillip because you do do this to us
that's [__]
you have told us over and over and over
again that you're just gonna I may I may
have said that twice
twice to come in here regularly and say
I'm going to close the doors if we keep
lying about [__] and we keep covering up
[__] and whatever then he ain't gonna
[__] help us and here we go like this
like we've been going for seven [__]
years
he's he's been he's been known to walk
behind the bar and fix himself drinks
after the staff Cuts him off
is that true
that I don't know about
that I don't know about I've got
I've gone on drinks yes so you're
blacked out you're that inebriated that
you've got no [__] idea that you're
that far gone he goes behind the bar
take the drink away from him he cannot
go in there in the first place why is he
even in that bar in the first place
to me it's hypocritical you put
a drink in the bar
Philip and we care about this place and
we care about you but a lot of us feel
like you don't give a damn about us
why are you coming in here to put your
your employees in a bad uncomfortable
situation if it was up to me I'd say
Philip you can't drink in here because
if something happens to you take out a
family of four they're coming after me
and my family and I don't have any money
to afford a lawyer keep me out of jail
for the rest of my life
[Music]
I'm at the Monticello Hotel in Longview
Washington where the staff are
confronting the owner about a drinking
problem if it was up to me I'd say
Philip you can't drink in here because
if something happens to you take out a
family of four they're coming after me
in my family
and I don't have any money to afford a
lawyer to keep me out of jail for the
rest of my life
they are telling you the truth because
they freaking care unfortunately you're
not telling the truth and that's why
this business is struggling this ship is
on a collision course
can I show you something I think you
should all see come with me
[Music]
I think everybody's forgotten what it's
like for guests to stay in this hotel
then hey Brooke how much is this room
250 a night Friday and Saturday is 180
the rest of the week let me show you
what 250 gets you at the Monticello and
turn the lights out
you see that this black light shows up
bodily fluids
the house in Arizona your house yes wow
those two holes there that's cigarette
holes Burns
[Music]
I was totally grossed out when I seen
that bed it was sickening 250 to sleep
in Phil
oh my God
that it's semen right there is
everywhere does that make anybody else
feel sick yeah because right now I am
[__] disgusted by this foul polluted
bed
I felt dirty I'm a clean person it was
disgusting I don't know why you're
running a hotel
ripping people off you don't care
for the customers now you don't care for
your staff who'd you care for
I care about my style
first thing you said to me when I
arrived here Philip what's the problem
staff they're bleeding the clock huh no
way
that's what you told me I've got half it
wrote and down at home where I put at
least 100 hours free in here
we will come in an hour two hours early
not punch in and then we will work late
to get what we need to get done
you have an estate to the tune of 10
[__] million dollars and a chef that
was a hundred hours in for nothing
or is he lying he's not lying he's here
all the time
I'm surprised you guys are here I'm the
only earner for my family and
I make 500 bucks every two weeks
it's looking crazy
[Music]
and you rock up here with a plate with
Hotel hell what the [__] is going on
these guys are your bread and butter
your [__] backbone but they're
terrified to tell you the truth you'll
keep on cutting corners
accumulating them because they're the
problem the fact that it's not busy look
within it starts from the [__] top
amen yeah
can you just excuse me for leaving here
on my own but Philip thank you
now can you [__] your man up I don't
have all the answers Gordon I'm trying
give me one [__] answer give me
something you're abusing your staff
what kind of message does it send to
them when you fill the car part with
classic cars and they're [__]
struggling
drink is fair but I think it's fair
enough no
do they deserve better
of course why are you doing it
I don't have an answer for that I don't
know why I'm doing that
okay leave me alone get the [__] out of
here
[Music]
sleeping in a tub is bloody
uncomfortable but it certainly beats
sleeping on that filthy mattress
[Music]
the staff have been as honest as they
can be but they're all afraid of losing
their jobs both of you come with me
please it's time Philip and ginger heard
from the people who aren't afraid to
tell them the truth uh good morning
everybody
thank you so much for coming
your guests are going to give you some
honest feedback
that room was dirty it looked like an
animal was killed and drug out the room
I mean the stain goes down the hall
there's no thought to the guest
experience at all wow you feel like you
threw your money down the drain
was so disappointed to know that I
couldn't stay in a piece of history and
got sent over to a motel
shocked at the decor that I saw it was
just hideous it was brutal to hear that
many guests complain about a one-night
experience in the hotel
it actually scares you away when you see
the Marquee that says there's a ladies
night and hiring part-time housekeepers
you don't want to advertise that you're
short on housekeeping whose stupid idea
was it to advertised for a part-time
housekeeper and I guess it's my idea
I'll take the responsibility thank you
can I ask you one question would you
come back and stay here please raise
your hands no never never
I appreciate your honesty thank you
[Music]
you heard what the guests had to say
yeah I did do me a favor spend a couple
of minutes here looking at what you've
inherited and ask yourself do you really
want it enough
do you really care enough
yes I do care
I don't think you do
[Music]
own a Philip and general manager Ginger
have just found out what the guests
really think about the Monticello Hotel
would you come back and stay here no
never
I think Ginger has finally realized how
much Philip's drinking is hurting the
hotel
and now she's asked to speak to me alone
because it's deep well this alcoholism
is very deep I can see it's been out
I've reached out to my children and
they've all talked to him
but it hasn't been any good and it's
getting worse the stress on my end has
been worthy at is he driving is he going
to kill somebody is he going to kill
himself
I just wish you told me the truth that's
all I am a private person
and this has been very hard and it's
hard to see someone destroy themselves
I don't even think he realizes how bad
it is it's been a very heavy burden not
me
he's very old it's a terrible disease
he's a new man and you're suffering the
consequences
[Music]
he needs help and that's the truth I'm
gonna persuade him to get treatment
would you do that for me I will do that
I want this place to work okay thank you
and I'm sorry
[Music]
I'm going to need the staff's help to
get through to Philip
come through guys maybe together we can
break through his denial
I'm gonna get
Philip in now and I need you to get
behind agreeing that he needs help
now it's hard
you're part of this change and you stand
up for what you feel is right this staff
needs him to show us that he's willing
to make a change I think he needs to
become honest with himself
this
hotel is a Breaking Point
and you need help
[Music]
is there anywhere else in this room that
thinks that Philip needs help with his
addiction please raise their hand
they're all here because each and every
one of them care
not just about the hotel but about you
Ginger you know
how bad the drinking problem is yes I do
I pour out bottles I empty them out down
the sink
because I love him and I hate to see him
destroy himself and that's what it's
been like it's been very hard
if you could see it through our eyes
it's like night and day during the day
you're just you're amazing Phillip you
talk to us with so much respect and
stuff like that and as soon as you start
drinking you can see that huge
difference come over you it's like the
black cloud We Really Care About You
Phillip
[Music]
we're afraid for you because you're Rock
Bottom isn't going to be like most
because you have the money to air way
out you have the money to do what you do
your Rock Bottom is going to be very
serious it's either going to kill you or
kill somebody else and I don't want to
see you die and I don't want to see you
in trouble and hurt somebody
you're very important you're worth
getting clean you're so worth it
okay Philip will you get help
and I'll keep on hiding this I don't
know what you want me to say Gordon what
about what you want to say
I'm not saying anything
we're done
if the entire staff can't get through to
Philip maybe speaking to Malone will
help change his mind he's got to get
help otherwise this place doesn't stand
a chance
when are you gonna snap inside and say
[__]
I'm hitting rock bottom I've been in
this position for the past several years
I'm sorry to hear that don't get upset
huh don't get upset
it's all part of it
so what you want to do for
[Music]
are you ready to get help
please
I promise I'm the blink away
from my family for my staff I'm going
into treatment
appreciate that come here it's time
some things in life are more important
than business and I'm glad Philip has
realized he has to put his health first
and sort out his problems
coming up
welcome to the new and improve
Monticello Hotel
[Music]
changes in the air at the Monticello
Hotel so overnight my design team gave
the hotel the makeover it truly deserves
morning morning
welcome to the new and improved
Monticello Hotel
before we go inside
I want you to notice something
that Dreadful Motel sign
has disappeared
when people want to make a booking you
can offer them a choice of the modern
Annex or the Historic Hotel and that
will be a lot easier because I've opened
up four new Suites for guests doubling
the number of rooms in this Historic
Hotel oh yes
let's go guys
I have butterflies I am so excited to
walk in that hotel I'm jumping ladies
oil
you're sweet
wow I love it oh my God
beautiful room they should be used for
guests not storage
never my wildest dreams
did I think our storage unit could end
up looking like this are you ready to
see the bedroom
oh cool I don't work gone there's all
that second-hand Furniture replaced by a
comfortable bed with luxurious Linens
now we have something to be proud of I
mean the place is absolutely gorgeous
stunning new furniture beautiful Linens
and beds for all your Suites very classy
it's mind-blowing what Gordon has done
is just phenomenal what do you think
I think that this is a room that I can
be proud to send my guests to Oh My
Goodness Me wonderful they're never
going to want to leave
now I'd like to show you my room
this is amazing for me the stunning
interior
matches the Majestic exterior now you
look on the outside you think this is
exactly the kind of feel you want inside
have a great look at the bedroom this
one you gotta love oh boy oh
I'm the best as you know with your
mattress full of stains now look that
beautiful bed that's what you call a
proper king size bed oh wow it was our
best room before and now it's the best
room in town
beautiful sure guys
the potential here
is phenomenal it's the heart of the town
again and something to be proud of
oh excuse me
welcome to Monticello stunning new room
service oh wow how can a hotel of this
standard not have a small Dynamic room
service menu increases the turnover I'll
never check but more importantly guess
they actually longer to know the food's
that good in the room as well
now get yourselves a plate and start
tasting oh wow this is so good those are
rotten potatoes yeah there's nothing
like fresh salmon that food was amazing
I can't recall the last time I tasted
food so fresh
I think it's going to be a real bonus
enjoy the rest of the food we've got a
big big night ahead of us it's a really
nice menu I think it's going to bring
the revenue higher this is exactly
exactly what we needed this is
sensational
it's not just room service I reinvented
the menu for the restaurant too using
the best local ingredients I'm confident
the combination of great food and great
rooms will encourage a whole new
generation to come here that's getting
medium in there it needs about another
minute or two then we'll pump that one
out okay the difference between the
Frozen and the food we're getting now
night and day there is it's
Indescribable for The Taste the
presentation it's awesome keep cooking
with fresh ingredients I will okay and
remember this the day a kitchen can't be
bothered to boil a [__] egg yeah get
out of there okay you're better than
that yes sir good job thank you yeah
well done thank you are you checking in
yes wow can I get your name uh
you're staying in one of our new sweets
I can't wait for people to see these
rooms oh wow and I'm ecstatic I'm gonna
have to send so many less guests out to
the motel this is what I had hoped for
although the guests are delighted with
the changes it looks like Chef Dan has a
problem quick word Oh no you're leaving
the Monticello's relaunch is going
brilliantly nice to see you Gordon you
okay
yeah but Chef Dan has just pulled me
aside take a seat
nine years clean this over well that's
phenomenal well done so I would love to
be a sponsor Phillips sponsor if you
would have me be a sponsor once he gets
out he's going to need somebody by his
side that's an amazing commitment
it's a real big responsibility to be a
field sponsor but it's one I'm willing
to take on get our owner on the right
track yeah good job thank you
to be a challenging Journey for Philip
but with all the support he has from
Ginger and his staff I'm hoping he'll be
able to stay away from alcohol so when
you get out of treatment you're gonna
need a sponsor somebody take your
meetings so nine years clean this over
if you want I offer
now with new life breathe into the
Monticello it's time for me to go
both of you
take care of yourselves okay good luck
thank you sir I'm seriously good luck oh
dear next time I see you
give me a change Matt oh yes I will one
more thing before I go okay what makes
this place
very special it's not just it's a
historic building it is 90th year for me
it's the staff so
just so you don't forget it here we are
a new plaque wonderful and the employers
of the month this month are entire staff
and you need to do more than just
recognize how good they are you need to
pay them properly yeah Ramsey did a
wonderful job the hotel is flowing in
the right direction because they do have
a good crew to turn the ship back around
and make it Thrive and I'm going to seek
help
for my drinking thank you Jordan
wow what a place
I really hope Philip keeps his promises
time will tell
since my visit to the Monticello hotel
bookings have gone up this is really
nice
and with all the new Revenue coming in
the staff are working with a new sense
of enthusiasm because Philip is finally
paying them properly for all the hours
they've put in Jordan I want to thank
you for what you did you saved 50
people's jobs and their livelihoods and
their families
and Philip is booked into a treatment
program which starts next week all I can
say is for Gordon is God bless you and
thank you